avec la situation épidémique les
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines vont rouvrir partiellement à
partir de cette semaine vous pourrez
profiter d'un service de drive pour
emprunter des documents dans certaines
médiathèques du réseau quant aux contes
et histoires qui sont à l'accoutumée
déclamer sur place pas de panique il
s'invitera directement chez vous depuis
mercredi dernier plusieurs rendez vous
sont proposés en ligne avec les
bibliothécaires du réseau on en parle
avec marie-pierre caruhel bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes la responsable de la
politique d'action culturelle pour le
réseau des médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines déjà une
première question pourquoi proposer ces
rendez vous en ligne
alors ces rendez vous en ligne ont été
proposés à la suite du confinement pour
le confinement 1 2 mois sans le public
sans pouvoir proposer en direct des
comptes comme on en a l'habitude et le
plaisir d'en proposer et donc les
bibliothécaires se sont mobilisés
pendant cette période pour proposer des
solutions en ligne
alors on aurait pu on aurait pu se
précipiter sur nos smartphones sur nos
tablettes pour proposer des solutions
pendant le confinement c'est pas le
choix qu'on a opéré un contrairement il
y avait beaucoup de propositions en
ligne déjà sur cette période on a
préféré prendre le temps nous organiser
et proposer une solution de qualité
cirque on a vraiment des films qui ont
été réalisés par des professionnels de
l'image et donc une solution qui
pourrait être pérenne
c'est une solution que nous proposons
actuellement jusqu'à la réouverture
pleine et entière des médiathèques
puisque le service public va être
partiellement proposé là avec une
proposition drive et médiathèques
rouvrir progressivement à partir de
juliet l'action culturelle en elle-même
ne va pas reprendre tout de suite
donc on espère pouvoir reprendre
normalement programme à partir de
septembre c'est pas le cas donc on va
proposer ses comptes en ligne à raison
d'un calendrier de madère un peu comme
comme d'habitude
on parlait juste dans un instant compris
que c'était très progressive juste nous
pour savoir ce qui était proposé
d'habitude aux médiathèques ses heures
de contes s'étaient proposés directement
sur place
en période normale avant l'avant le
confinement c'est comme ça que ça se
déroule tout à fait d'habitude dans
chaque médiathèque
enfin sur les douze médiathèque de saint
quentin vous pouvez assister à des hors
du conte pour les petits pour les grands
selon un calendrier hebdomadaire
régulier c'est vraiment le rendez-vous
des médiathèques habituel et c'est un
rendez-vous qui manquait aux enfants aux
parents ils vous ont fait remonter cette
envie de revoir les comptes réapparaître
d'une certaine manière la sas est
proposé en ligne est ce qu'il ya eu une
attente de la part des parents et des
enfants
il l'attend essentiel est quand même sur
le service public sur la proposition des
documents de pouvoir emprunter des
documents je pense que c'est la tempe
essentiel maintenant on a eu des retours
très positifs depuis la mise en ligne de
ces comptes puisque nous avons déjà eu
la leur tour par exemple d'une
assistante maternelle d'un papa qui nous
dit que c'était vraiment formidable que
m'avait proposé gérer que c'est plus une
satisfaction qu'une attente vraiment
crucial on comprendre que c'est un peu
la problématique aussi de 2,2 des
solutions en ligne il ya pléthore de
solutions allaient maintenant jeu qui va
faire notre différence c'est que les
enfants qui ont l'habitude de voir
certaines bibliothèques arbres pouvoir
retrouver les visages les visages
familiers
c'est s'appelait différence par rapport
à une offre
tu ne serais pas locale mais et vous le
disiez ce sont des vidéos
professionnelles avec de l'image en plus
des comptes est aussi bas les
bibliothécaires vous en parliez qui ont
été mis à contribution les
bibliothécaires du réseau des
médiathèques
oui tout à fait les écarts se sont
mobilisés c'est vraiment une aile une
attente très forte qu'elle avait de
pouvoir faire cette proposition à leur
public
donc on a une dizaine de bibliothèques
garder jacques et son big listière pour
pour participer à ces séances de contes
alors trois ont déjà été mises en ligne
depuis mercredi dernier
l'idée c'est vous en parliez tout à
l'heure de les proposer régulièrement
jusqu'à une certaine période le caler le
calendrier
justement actuellement nous vous
proposons trois contes par semaine
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août au moins
dire que tant que les médiathèques ne
sont pas ouvertes nous nous proposerons
cette offre en ligne et nous la
garderons sire que les comptes sont
dévoilés progressivement toutes les
semaines vous allez trois rendez vous
par semaine et pour les comptes en fait
qui restent libres de droit donc à
savoir les cons les comptines jeux de
doigts
les contes traditionnels tous ses
comptes vont être proposées aussi sur le
portail des médiathèques vous pourrez
avoir accès au delà de la période de
programmation assez assez assez compte
via le portail i médiathèque avec une
page dédiée spéciale pour ses comptes en
ligne mais j'allais vous demander quels
étaient les comptes mise en ligne est ce
que il ya des comptes qui se prêtent
plus facilement à cet exercice de les
dire en ligne finalement est ce que il
ya une sélection qui a été fait pour
pour cette mise en ligne alors la
sélection n'a pas été différente de
celle que l'on propose d'habitude y
mènent des collègues ont essayé de
retrouver l'interactivité qu'on a
d'habitude avec un public présent avec
des comptines par exemple on peut
répéter à la suite de la bibliothécaire
vous avez des décomptes qui sont dit
vous avez des livres qui sont lus et
dans ces cas là on a aussi l'image du
livre qui est accessible et qui est
incrusté en fait du temps d'imagés donc
au fur et à mesure que la bibliothèque à
raconte vous avez aussi les images du
livre qui s'affiche et ils vous le
disais donc trois rendez vous par
semaine là le prochain c
alors le prochain c'est mercredi mardi
matin pour les petits pour les petits là
on vous attend dès mercredi matin et
tous ses comptes a retrouvé bien sûr sur
le portail i médiathèque merci marie
pierre caruhel d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous et je rappelle que vous
êtes à la responsable de la politique
d'action culturelle pour le réseau des
médiathèques de saint quentin en
yvelines